few results of a study on breast cancer
are expected to change treatment for
thousands of women in the early stages
of the disease the study of more than
10,000 women found that many of them did
not need chemotherapy to prevent the
cancer from returning or spreading our
dr. David agus leads the university of
southern california's westside cancer
center he joins us from Los Angeles good
morning dr. morning Nora so 70% of women
with early-stage breast cancer may not
need chemotherapy who specifically may
benefit this is exciting these are women
with a hormone receptor-positive
estrogen receptor-positive and a marker
called her2 negative breast cancer
historically we've been doing this test
which looks at the 21 genes that are
turned on and turned off in the cancer
and many of them didn't need cancer I
mean chemotherapy and some of them did
but most fell in the middle 65,000 women
a year fell in this indeterminate region
and these women were heroes they went
into a clinical trial the largest ever
done in breast cancer were half just got
hormonal therapy and half were given
chemotherapy and hormonal therapy and
what they showed is no benefit to
chemotherapy in these women so another
65 thousand women a year will
definitively not need chemotherapy for
early breast cancer so who falls into
the category what determines whether you
get it or you don't get it now so these
are the most common subtype of breast
cancer estrogen receptor positive and
her2 negative now after a biopsy where
the cancer is taken out this test will
be done and these 21 genes looked at and
the doctor will be able to look down and
tell you definitively you need
chemotherapy you'll benefit or you won't
so it takes out that indecision and
really allows a great communication with
either patient the doctor in the best
outcome and so if you don't do
chemotherapy doctor then what exactly
are you doing and where are the
potential side effects or risks of that
so in these women the estrogen receptor
pathway is turned on too they're giving
a drug that blocks that pathway either
tamoxifen or what's called an aromatase
inhibitor that blocks the production of
estrogen and their side effects to it
joint aches and hot flashes but
certainly significantly less than
chemotherapy some women will still need
chemotherapy though
the ones that a higher score on this
test and they'll benefit from
chemotherapy but many now won't let me
ask you dr. David agus is there as a nun
colleges it is this common now not
common I should say but it's growing
that less cancers need chemotherapy I
will answer this for you Norah O'Donnell
[Laughter]
yeah we're getting to be able to
personalize treatment now and so in the
in the old days we would just have a
bucket breast cancer prostate cancer
lung cancer now we can look at the
subtypes of cancer by looking at the
genes and giving the right treatment to
the right patient at the right time and
this is the promise of personalized
medicine and it's arrived all right dr.
David agus thanks so much exciting again